ohtani knight always gets a lot of
attention here at home
as the angels take the field eager to
snap out of a three-game
funk it's going to be right-hander
shohei ohtani we've seen him hit we've
seen him hit well
in this series and now we're going to
see him pitch making his fourth start of
the season couple numbers to take a peek
at right here
13 and two thirds innings how about that
strikeout to walk
strikeouts outstanding walks
not so much with 13 to 13 to two-thirds
the opponent's average
you have a hard time hitting him but he
will do you some favors so i expect this
raised lineup
to be patient with ohtani make him prove
that he's going to be in the zone
and he loses low on four pitches to
start the ball game this
is in part the uh the ray's dna
for winning baseball they are a
unapologetic
three true outcome roster so stepping up
to the plate now
is meadows here's the pitch and this is
popped in the air into right center
field routine play
under making the grab is mike trout
medium right center and that will be the
first out
so one away two walks in the inning
that moves diaz up to second
wendell takes over at first oh for 21
against the split
and there's a swing and a miss and that
was a splitter struck him out and the
inning is over
if you drop some change into the sofa
cushions and you miss andrew kittridge
tonight
it's because he's only going to be out
there for an inning
the rays utilizing the opener tonight of
course they always reserve the right to
change their mind and we could see
kidridge for more than an inning
but the expectation is kitt ridge and
then ryan yarbrough
as the bulk guy tonight for tampa bay
ford a young man out of
fresno state who's after the first pitch
chopped to third point's throw is there
in time to get him
to ward in that lineup and going after
that first pitch
and listen up there to swing the bat two
up and two down
and here is mike trout the last three
games the angels have had
a total of only 17 hits
so it's a little over five hits a game
the pitch that's lined into
right center and there to make the grab
on that one is the center fielder
kiermeier trout hit it hard
squalls and two strikes to count to
willy adams yeah he went
he went you bet there's a splitter and
that one was
waved at weekly by adamus he was fooled
struck
him out and the inning ends
here in the second the way it ended in
the top of the first on a strikeout
big picture in the early going with
kitridge trying to keep it scoreless the
ryanair set and ready to go there go the
runners and the payoff pitches grounded
diving at shortness willie adams from
shadow left bounces his throat to first
and he's out at first base thankfully a
catcher was running
because it didn't just bounce it bounced
and rolled to first and yoshi tatsugo
able to dig it out
and willie adamus with a tremendous play
from short
and a tip of the camp to yoshi for
securing the out and the angels turned
away
in this second what a play by williams
here's austin meadows now on the first
pitch hot shot
oh yeah i'm sorry
please sorry bro i'm just too
coordinated to not make that play
it's like okay what can't show hey we
know he can feel this position now
drive up the middle goes yeah i got it
that's a beautiful moment hey man my bad
better now for the angels is jared walsh
crowd intentionally walked they're
loaded
and walsh takes ball forward about four
pitch bases loaded walk yarbrough didn't
miss by much on either
of those angels get the run to start the
scoring tonight
one-nothing fletcher third trout second
walsh at first big pitch here on two and
two
swinging a ground ball left side right
to wendell he'll go the short route to
second to get the out
and that will retire the side they force
out walsh so
minimal damage done two runners in
scoring position trying to strand the
second of two here
there's a 2-2 splitter that's chased and
missed phillips is a strikeout victim
second strikeout in the inning for
ohtani is fifth in the game
and that'll do it for the raise here one
out with two on and here's david
fletcher back to the top of the order
one for two in the game today first
pitch here is rope the third caught by
wendell throws back to second
but a double play the line out double
play goes five to four
that was a tight wire rope to third
crowd for one was intentionally walked
his last time
one gun base is empty one-nothing angels
last of the fifth
same spot again no prob not real happy
about it and there's no way you can get
out of the way that one yeah that's
right give him the raspberry yeah we got
some enforcers in the crowd tonight
shohei officially goes five he allowed
one hit at the moment no runs two
on base he had seven strikeouts in the
game 84 pitches 47 for strikes
now they have runners everywhere with
one out
satsugo is the batter here's the pitch
and he bounces this one by rodriguez
out to second on the bag touching it and
then firing the first bases iglesias
and that will end the inning how about
that that was a ball there that was
basically back to the mound but it went
under the glove of chris rodriguez so
again the raise with the first two
hitters aboard
now the top of the order brandon loud
[Applause]
home run to center field off the batter
brandon lau
and the raids just like that are on the
board and take the lead three to one
fifth home run of the season for brandon
lau and he got a pitch he can handle he
got it up in the air and it cleared the
wall
and landed in the shrubbery out there
this has been a rough outing here for
garrett come in with the wall
struggling with command and location and
that's
center cut one pitch one out the eighth
inning is underway
whether he's holding this three-to-one
leader
will head to second base ward with the
pickup and it's
a two-base hit for yoshi tsutsugo
pitchers back on the pitching rubber and
angel hitter gosling back in the box
we'll see what happens on the next one
here it comes
and it's hit right to the shortstop
might be two second for one relay to
first
close but in time for the out
the o2 swinging a ground ball to the
right of the mound lau will
charge scoop and throw to first in time
and that'll take care of the angels here
in the eighth so they get a lead off
base it
they get him the third but they can't
get him in two up and
two down in the night the angels are
down to their last try tonight
and a swing and a miss and he closes
this one out
and will get a save in the victory that
goes to yarbrough the rays win this one